well the bad weather could make for
treacherous driving conditions for many
drivers it remains brutal in parts of
the West because of a powerful storm
that left people stranded for many hours
near the Oregon California border
earlier this week this morning the main
highway their interstate 5 has fully
reopened transportation correspondent
Kris Van Cleave has been tracking the
holiday rush as travelers made their way
closer to Thanksgiving meals they paced
harsh weather across the country two
storms dumped heavy snow in the West and
brought winds and rain to the east
Wednesday many drivers in Minnesota
spent the day digging out crashes and
spinouts tied up traffic for miles the
weather also caused delays at airports
where nearly 4.5 million Americans were
expected to fly this Thanksgiving
holiday hour
Amtrak has more trains operating at its
major hubs so you're gonna find extra
staffing stations extra trains an expert
capacity but most Americans are hitting
the roads like we did we are on the move
from downtown Boston an early start did
not save us from running into holiday
traffic on Interstate 95 on our Trek to
DC not even going 20 miles an hour right
now and we were not alone a trip that
should have taken in about an hour took
maybe about two two and a half hours but
we finally made it driving from Boston
to Washington on a good day takes about
eight hours it's around 440 miles this
was not a good day this was the day
before Thanksgiving and it took more
than 11 hours but we have just now
finally crossed into Washington for CBS
this morning Kris Van Cleave Washington